hello and welcome to this video against
the opening magician ok that's an how
long mm-hmm Valley new home plate him
before yeah he plays one of the critical
lines in the ratty gambit sorry ok e six
min it is fairly well
quite remember how this is played with
it I will see ya both pawn takes and
drew takes is interesting we're both
interesting
Wow
wow so 94 what's the point disappoint
osb for that idea makes before simply
96 96 bishop c6 loop effects okay
but now 95 or something oh my goodness
that's a cool defense if it works him
not even sure if I can take c4 anyway
due to 95 as a reply and probably I can
take it well let's see what he does we
should a six on how to save now in
hindsight I should have taken with the
porn on a three that was some more
conservative option yeah it takes ages
there what are you doing
Jeff it's hard not to take c6 really
even though we certainly have something
I mean here says something is a in
precise way to phrase that even though
it certainly is okay for him I mean it's
um it was difficult to play something
else yes so and as somehow we need to
get get pieces out and this is difficult
oh that's a remarkably bad position now
that I think of it more closely it's
amazing
I cannot do anything here would even see
how I can maybe like to sacrifice a pawn
for some kind of plane
it even sure that this was best and it
is good for him I mean just cream takes
probably create form honey okay baby
then t4 is still somewhat somewhat some
kind of resistance amazing how bad this
position is so amazing okay so Quincy
success is coming
should go for basically
you
yeah this is a time morning this is more
more demoralizing kids what six look
[Laughter]
great what a great game Wow okay that's
really rare like designed to just get
completely outplayed from start to
finish the abbey takes a spectrum yeah I
kind of suspected this this is how I
usually take them because you have an
easier time to develop on the B file and
so on but this happy 5 is shocking
really it got really really troublesome
quickly yeah d3 is the alternative of
course is one way to make sense of the
book there but besides as just wrong
this is just very strong Kim and I
probably gavel if I don't take on c6
what is the point of my plane nothing is
the point and here the position is just
totally sucks up should be 50 that I
should have played ads much better it
was just now that was a very minor
smooth but you know I simply I simply
didn't didn't see b5 as a square I was
just thinking okay I'm on the long
diagonal and I stay down
okay I'm p.m. toaster just totally
totally lost already okay three wasn't
that again ah because I can take on b3
okay let's at least some kind of fight
and yeah it's just amazing yeah oh yeah
I think this is Sally normally for it's
also quite normal down here and you have
to take with the Hornets better let's
get there should be two and he isn't he
doesn't easily am cover stuff with p5
now this is really a lot better ok guys
thanks for watching